Greetings people of the world.
For years, you've been under the assumption that my uncle Inspector Gadget was a respected detective
for the Metro City Police Force.
This was all just a cunning ruse.
Did you really think such a bumbling dick with the voice of Don Adams could accomplish super impossible feats
and still be human?
For God's sake! He has a f**king helicopter in his head!
And yet, nobody questions where the hell his brain is!
I created the Gadget 9000 prototype
and you dumbasses fell for it!
And now that I've created artificial life, I shall unleash it on an unsuspecting world!
Your tanks and stealth bombers are no match for the hellfire I'm about to unleash!
Do you know how difficult it was to constantly be in the shadows as that incompetent SHIT got all the credit?!
I compressed the entire internet into my textbook!
Taught a canine how to simulate human speech
and created the Apple Watch before Steve Jobs was out of his mother's basement!
Gimme another ten years! I would've created a f**king Matrix
complete with a Keanu Reeves that can actually act!
You thought the real enemy was M.A.D. but they were merely a distraction.
As long as Gadget and Claw fought, the police were always occupied.
For you see, I was foiling M.A.D.'s plans so that when the time came
I could seize control of your governments
your thermal nuclear warheads
YOUR LIVES!!
I am PENNY! Mother of gadgets!
Breaker of brains!
I will take back the honor that was stolen from me and destroy those who stand in my way!
Isn't that right Uncle Gadget?
*WOWZERS*
Penny for your thoughts, bitches!
Does that work?
Ya but, you were supposed to just say
"Ooo, I don't like that Uncle Gadget."
Ya, not anymore
Okay